there is New Hope for the millions
worldwide who suffer from Alzheimer's
disease a late stage trial of the Eli
Lilly drug de nanamob shows its slows
cognitive decline by as much as 35
percent the drug is a monoclonal
antibody designed to remove amyloid
plaque which is one of the defining
features of Alzheimer's from the brain
for the past 20 years or so we've had
drugs available that work on the
symptoms but really do not get at the
underlying biology of the disease so
dynanimab is a drug that gets at the
underlying disease process a so-called
disease modifying therapy current
research finds the drug effective for
those with mild cognitive impairment or
mild dementia but researchers say it is
possible that the drug could be
effective for those who show no signs of
Alzheimer's but whose biology suggests
they could develop symptoms later
supportive doesn't stop the disease
it doesn't make people better but it may
slow the rate at which they decline
potential side effects include swelling
or bleeding in the brain so researchers
recommend periodic MRI scans and play
the piano Lily plans to file for
approval by June and hopes Regulators
will give you the green light by early
next year John hendron Al Jazeera